I'm not gonna stay at my house I'm not
gonna let anybody tell me that I need to
stay home not only is he not staying
home country star chase rice played a
concert on Saturday and now some of
country music's biggest stars are
speaking out and slamming the singer for
his apparent disregard for coronavirus
safety precautions I was counting oh
this is a nice break I'm gonna take
advantage of this exit like this but now
it's getting too forward
here's what went down on Saturday chase
played a concert in Petros Tennessee and
shared this video on his Instagram story
Kelsea Ballerini posted it to Twitter
writing imagine being selfish enough to
put thousands of people's health at risk
the 26 year old singer tagged chase
adding we all want and need to tour we
just care about our fans and their
families enough to wait but chase wasn't
the only singer who put on a live show
over the weekend fellow country star
Chris Jamison also played a concert on
Saturday in Feiler Idaho and he got heat
to the indie folk rock band the mountain
goats chimed in criticizing the artists
the venue's and those in attendance for
assuring that conscientious musicians
won't be able to work their jobs for a
while adding to be blunt that sucks
Maron mortis retweeted that post and
shortly after she shared this screenshot
showing that Chris had blocked her on
Twitter seemingly confused by the
alleged Block Maron asked what did I do
country singer cam tweeted that Chase
and Chris as individuals are low-hanging
fruit along with a New York Times
excerpt about contacting and calling out
local government officials and people of
power to initiate change Chase's
Tennessee concert venue the historic
Brushy Mountain State Penitentiary
addressed the controversy in a statement
to ET insisting quote all local
requirements were abided by for the
recent concert and numerous precautions
were taken as for Chris he posted about
his Saturday performances a few times
but later deleted them all a rep for
Chris has not yet replied to et's
request for
comment and a rap for Chase had no
comment I know a lot of people are being
politically correct and doing the right
thing and stay at home and I haven't I
stayed home but it the part to me is
like people are like stay home don't go
anywhere it's like where are you gonna
go yeah I want to go aren't open Jase
spoke to et back in May about how he's
handled the nationwide shutdowns and
social distancing mandates amid the
global pandemic I'm not gonna let
anybody tell me that I need to stay home
I'm gonna go to my buddy's house I'm
gonna go to to another buddy's house
like we got three houses we keep don't
then I personally don't think CNN I'm
gonna laugh more I've hung out more I've
sat around the dinner table more I've
gotten to know these people that
otherwise I was just buddies with now
we're like oh yeah this now we're
actually real close group of people so
if you consider that breaking the rules
yeah broken with the best of them got a
blast and I don't think that we put
anybody in danger he's been fine I also
don't leave all the hype of this thing
anyway I think it's serious I think some
people are dying obviously which is a
big deal but I don't think it's near as
big a deal as people are making doubts
but that's not in my control like all I
can control with my life and I'm having
a blast I've loved every second
[Music]